I'm now going to introduce an
ancient method for generating
a list of primes
up to some limit
N called the Sieve
of Eratosthenes.
Now, Eratosthenes
was born in 276 BC,
so this method is
over 2,200 years old,
but it's very
simple and elegant,
and you could teach
it to any child.
Now let's say, for
example, we want
to calculate all the
primes up to 100.
But this would work
in the same way
if we wanted to calculate
up to 10,000 or a billion.
It proceeds as follows.
Assume all numbers are unmarked.
Gray is unmarked.
We start at the
beginning, and if we
find a number that is
unmarked, we know it's prime.
So we hit 2, and we say 2 is
prime because it's unmarked.
And then the second
phase is now we
can eliminate all
multiples of 2,
because we know
they're composite.
So bam, we jump along and we
eliminate all multiples of 2.
Red means composite.
And now we repeat.
We step along from 2 to 3.
3 is unmarked, so
we mark 3 as prime.
And now we can eliminate
all multiples of 3.
And a really simple
optimization is
notice 6 is already crossed off.
We actually cross
off the multiples
starting at the
square of that number.
So 3 times 3 is 9.
We start at 9 and mark all
multiples of 3 as composite.
And again, we go back.
We jump along to 4.
Well, 4 is marked, we
know it's composite,
and we jump along to 5.
We found an unmarked number.
5 is prime.
Now, 5 times 5 is 25.
We go to 25, we mark off 25,
30, 35, 40, 45, and so on.
Those are composites.
We proceed forward
until we hit 7.
We know 7 is prime
because it's unmarked.
7 times 7 is 49.
We mark 49 and all multiples
of 7 above it as composite.
And now we move along
until we hit 11.
11 is prime.
And notice now, 11 times
11 is greater than 100,
so we can actually
stop at this point.
We could have
stopped at 10 even,
because now all remaining
unmarked numbers,
if you'll notice, are prime.
And we could in one swoop
mark them all as prime.
And that's the whole algorithm.
It's so simple.
And just to generalize how we
do this, so we could write up
a program to perform
this sieve, is
if we want to find all
primes up to some number N,
we first create a main loop.
So we have 4, all numbers a
from 2 to the square root of n.
So notice here we stopped.
When we hit 10, or
I showed it as 11,
we actually stop because
we have found all primes.
So from 2 to the square root
of N, we proceed as follows.
If a is unmarked, then
we know a is prime,
and when we find
a prime number, we
mark all multiples of
a off as composite.
And that's it.
So you find a number prime,
mark off the multiples,
go back to the beginning,
increment a by one.
So we're on 2, then we go to 3,
then we go to 4, 5, and so on.
And when we're done,
we have all primes.
Notice here that
this is also a loop.
So we have a main loop 4,
and when we find a prime,
this marking off of
multiples is also a loop.
So it's important to notice
here that we have a nested loop.
We have a loop inside a loop.
Here is an example of
this algorithm in action--
I wrote in JavaScript
below-- if I put in 100, here
are all the primes under 100.
And if I put in 200, here
are all the primes under 200.
And if I put in 850, here
are all the primes under 850.
And below, I have this program
with a recording explaining
how I set it up.